字幕: Kanami Mimo Nagano
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
(拍手)
何かを残すことを意識したことってありますか
何かを残すって
「何かに」とか「誰かに」という
対象が無いと
なかなか意識しづらいことのようにも思えます
そもそも残すということ自体
あまり普段の生活だと意識しないですよね
私も好きな食べ物は
後で食べたいから みたいなところでしか
残すなんて考えもしません
個人的にはラーメンが大好物なんですけれども
これは残すなんてこれっぽっちも考えませんが
食べ物でこういう例え話をするのは
あまりよくないかもしれません
そんな刹那的な生活をしている私ですけれども
今は 何かを残すという
ボランティアをしています
その何かというのは
価値のあるアイデアです
そもそも価値のあるアイデアって何でしょうか
誤解を恐れず 個人的な視点で言うんだったら
社会や誰かにとって役に立つアイデア
というのが
ひとつの答えなんじゃないかな
というふうに思います
別に 万人に向けてというわけではありません
もしかしたらすごく少数の方にしか
響かないかもしれない
でも大切なのは
「誰か」に「何かを残す」
ここでは価値のあるアイデアを
残すことについて
お話しようかなというふうに思っています
そして 誰に残したいかですが
これは話の最後にとっておこうと思います
私はTEDxKyotoという団体で
ボランティアをしています
ライセンシー オーガナイザーと
大層な肩書きがありますけれども
なにかに秀でているというわけではありません
こちらにいらっしゃる
TEDxHamamatsuの皆さんや
日本のTEDx
そして世界のTEDxで
活動されている人たちと同じように
価値のあるアイデアを広げよう
Ideas Worth Spreading
というスローガンのもと
2012年から活動を続けています
ちなみに私はTEDxKyotoの
代表ではありますが
2018年からの代表で２代目になります
こちらに写っているJayというリーダーが
2012年にこの団体を立ち上げました
その頃から 私はデザイナーとして
この活動に参加しています
そして 2018年にJayからこの団体を
引き継いだというふうな形になります
毎回 このTEDxKyotoを
どういうふうに作り上げるかと
様々なボランティア達と
ああでもない こうでもない
どうしたら参加者の方たちに
素晴らしい機会を提供できるかと
いつも議論をしているところです
残念ながら 2020年 2021年と
コロナで開催することはできませんでしたが
そんな活動を続けて
そろそろ10年が経とうとしています
参加当初から私は
このTEDのスローガンである
価値のあるアイデアを広げよう
Ideas Worth Spreading
とはまた別の理由からこの活動に参加して
未だにその想いは変わっていません
いや 少しずつ変わってきてるかなという
ところもあるんですけれども
根本的なところは
全然変わってないなというところです
進歩が無いなと思うところもあるのですが
あまりにも変わらないので
これが私にとって
最も大切なことなんじゃないかな
と思うようになりました
それは最初にお話しした
価値のあるアイデアを
残していきたいということです
「残すこと」という言葉を
別の言い方にするんだったら
「アーカイブ」という言葉に
言い換えられるかもしれません
TEDのいう スプレッディング
広げること ではないんですね
残すこと アーカイブです
このボランティアをするにあたって
この残したいという想いが
広げたいということよりも
もっと先に私が強く 強く意識した言葉でした
そもそも アーカイブって何でしょうか
もちろん もともとは英語なんですけれども
公文書とか記録保存
文書 そのもののことを言うかもしれませんし
保存をするということでもあります
恐らく皆さんも 日常でよく使われている言葉
なんじゃないかなとも思いますし
最近になったら デジタル環境でよく
使われている言葉なんじゃないかなと思います
では アーカイブを残すこと
何かを残すことの意味って 何でしょうか
パソコンやインターネットが生まれる前は
書籍や映像がその役割を果たしてきました
さまざまな方の考え方や想い 物語を
紙面上に残して それを蓄積した
後世に残してきた
そのような意味合いかなというふうに思います
そして図書館がその蓄積を残しつつ
多くの人々がその蓄積を参照して
新しいものを作り上げるために
夢想し続けてきたんじゃないかな
というふうに思います
アーカイブは過去の知を紡ぎつつ 継承し
発展のきっかけをくれるものかもしれません
ドイツの有名な宰相のビスマルクは
こんな言葉を残しました
愚者は経験に学び 賢者は歴史に学ぶ
結構有名な言葉なので
ご存知の方も多いんじゃないかな
というふうに思うんですけれども
愚者は自分が経験して 色々なことに気付いて
そこから学んでいく
ですが 賢者は過去の他の方の経験から
様々なことを学んで
事前に予測して活動することができる
そのような意味合いなんじゃないかなと
私は思っています
自分が経験していない 他の方の経験から
その人の考え方や生き方を学ぶことができる
受け取ることができる と言い換えても
いいんじゃないかなというふうに思います
もちろん そこから何かを学んでどう動くか
何を経験するか したいかというのが
もっと大切なのかもしれません
ちょっと視点を変えて子どもの頃の話を
しようかなと思います
この世界を
父や母 祖父母
周りの大人たちから少しずつ学んで
自分のものにしてきた あの頃を思い出します
そして
様々な書籍を読み漁った 小さな頃
自分はよく思い出します
恐らく私は自分が全然経験していないことを
様々な人たち 様々な書籍から受け取り
自分の行動の指針にしてきたような気がします
どうでしょう
皆さんも多くの人々
多くの書籍 多くの映像から
いろいろなことを吸収して
学んで動いてきたのではないでしょうか
そのおかげで失敗が少なく
行動することができた
ということもあるかもしれませんが
私はどちらかというと
前者 愚者側ですので
様々な壁にぶつかり
失敗をしてきた方だと思います
さて
もう少し話を前に進めていこうかな
というふうに思います
私は なんで
価値のあるアイデアをアーカイブしていきたい
と思い続けているんでしょうか
そして 誰のために
答えは すごくシンプルです
自分の子どものためです
自分でも わかりやすい性格をしているな
というふうには思うんですが
私にとっては シンプルで
すごく大切な答えです
新しい命が生まれた誕生と同時に
感動と同時に
私の中にひとつの気付きが生まれました
それは死です
ありがちな話ではありますが
この一言が私の中にふっと浮かんできました
新しい命が生まれたんだったら
古いものは死ぬ　当たり前の話ですよね
だったら 私の考え方や経験
そして私の周りで素晴らしい活動をしている人
面白いことをしている人たちを
子どもたちに知ってほしい
この世の中は 理不尽なことも
めちゃめちゃ多いんだけれども
すごく楽しい世界が広がっているんだよと
子どもたちに残していきたい
そういうふうに思ったんですよね
これは極めて個人的な想いです
そんな折 ありがたいことに
この想いを実社会で活動できる
プラットフォームが京都で生まれたんですよね
ご縁って本当に不思議なものだなと思います
子どもが生まれるまでは
こんなことをこれっぽっちも思ってなかったな
というふうには思うんですけれども
偶然にも TEDの創始者である
リチャード・ソール・ワーマンの書籍を
高校の時に手に取ったというのも
何かのご縁だったのかもしれません
アーカイブは
何かを考えるためのきっかけでもあり
余白を作り出してくれるものなんじゃないかな
というふうに思います
そして そのきっかけが
新しい好奇心を 私たちの中に
作り出してくれるんじゃないかな
そういうふうに私は思っています
皆さんはいかがでしょうか
次の世代が また次の世代が
このアーカイブたちをどのように使うのか
私たちは知る由もありません
新しくて素晴らしい発見やイノベーションが
生まれるかもしれない
逆にもしかしたら
こちらが想定していない
間違った使い方をするかもしれません
ちょっと無責任な言い方に
なるかもしれませんが
私はそれでいいかなというふうに思っています
私たちは こういうアイデアを探すツールを
いろんなところから
受け取ってきているのではないでしょうか
もちろん
そのツールたちをどのように
探すだけではだめ
知っているだけではだめ
どう使うかだろう というふうに
思うかもしれません
ですが きっかけが無ければ
何も始まりません
もし何も知らなければ
行動しよう という考えさえも
浮かばないかもしれません
私たちは
未来に少しずつ 少しずつ何かを残しています
未来に希望を持って
何かを残すことしかできない
単純に それしかできないんじゃないかな
というふうに思いますが
もしかしたら
それはもしかしたら誰かの
道標になるかもしれません
ここまでいろいろなお話を
させていただきましたが
実は最近は 少しずつ
考え方が変わってきていまして
今 この最後で ここで言うんかいという
話なんですけれども
この活動を通して
自分の子どもから孫へ とか
まだ孫はいないんですけれども
家族へとか
周りの人々へと 対象が少しずつ
広がりつつあります
どうして広がってきているのだろうなと
自問自答することもあるんですが
その答えのひとつは
この活動を通して素晴らしい考え方やアイデア
そして 人々にお会いすることが
本当に増えたんですよね
なので その素晴らしいものたちを
多くの人たちと共有していきたい
知ってほしいというふうに思ったから
なんじゃないかなというふうに思います
たぶん 私は
皆さんと一緒に歩きながら そして話しながら
アーカイブを作り続けていきたい
古くて新しくて 私がまだ知らない
素晴らしいアイデアに触れ合いながら
それを皆さんと一緒に
作り続けていきたい
残し続けていきたいんじゃないかな
というふうに考えています
今日 この場にいる皆さんが
残すことの楽しさを感じていただければ
とても嬉しいなというふうに思いますし
これからも皆さんと一緒に
素晴らしいアイデアを残し続けていければな
というふうに思っています
ありがとうございました
(拍手)